[Musique]
c'est une exposition en pleine nature
qui se dévoile au cœur même du jardin
botanique de mascara ses œuvres
réalisées par des collégiens dans le
cadre du projet Land Art sont présentés
scénarisés avec des haïku ses poèmes
courts sur les sentiments et les
sensations du quotidien
qu'est-ce que vous avez voulu donner
comme message
la nature des ombres soleil de la
lumière et
surtout venez bonjour
est porté par le département de La
Réunion on association avec le rectorat
de son collégiens scolarisés au sein de
cinq établissements sur l'île se sont
initiés au cyanotypes un procédé ancien
utilisé pour la photographie monochrome
des plantes du jardin ont ainsi été
imprimés avec cette technique sur du
tissu on va dire imprimer dessus et en
fait avec des jeux de lumière les la
partie au soleil va devenir bleu et la
partie à l'ombre de rester blanche c'est
pour ça qu'on voit le contour de nos
de nos plantes là aujourd'hui voir
autant d'oeuvres avec autant de
créativité de créativité d'imagination
que les enfants ont mis à travers la
production et bien ça me fait voir le
jardin d'un autre œil donc je me dis que
la culture le côté scientifique est
assuré par la nouvelle génération donc
je on va on va soutenir fortement dans
les années à venir le projet Land Art au
niveau des collèges cette exposition
commune baptisée projet cyanotype est
visible à Mascara jusqu'au mois de juin
[Musique]